لقد شاهدت صور الأقمار الصناعية التي تشير إلى أن مقاتلات F-16 التركية موجودة في واحدة على الأقل من قواعدك التي لم تشتريها من طراز f-16 ، فهل هذا صحيح أن هناك طائرات f-16 على الأرض من شأنها أن توحي بدعم كبير لأذربيجان وأنا أتفق مع أنت عندما تقول على الأرض أن مقاتلات F-16 جاءت إلى أذربيجان لإجراء مناورات عسكرية العام الماضي ، وأذربيجان وتركيا ، و 10 مناورات عسكرية مشتركة ، تركيا هي حليفنا ومن الشائع هنا إجراء مناورات عسكرية بما في ذلك القوات الجوية بالمناسبة هذا العام بسبب جائحة لم يكن لدينا سوى تمرينين عسكريين أحدهما كان فقط أه قبل وقوع الهجوم الأرميني على أذربيجان لذا فإن طائرات F-16 على الأرض لا تطير ولا تشارك بأي شكل من الأشكال في أي نوع من المعارك أه أنت قاطع في ذلك سيدي هل أنت لا تستخدم هذه الطائرات من طراز F-16 في المعركة ، يمكنني أن أخبرك أنه يمكنني أن أخبرك عن مزيفة أرمينية واحدة في الأيام الأولى من الاشتباكات قالوا إن مقاتلة F-16 التركية أغلقت أرمينيا  su-25
هذا مزيف ويجب على أولئك الذين
يتهموننا بهذا
الآن أن يعتذروا لأن الجميع
يعلم أن هذا شيء
f-16s موجود هنا لكنهم على الأرض
كما ذكرت بشكل صحيح